this year we may have a record number of
nominees who are graduates of Carnegie
Mellon University and so yes it is a
great pleasure to introduce the
president of CMU dr. subra Suresh and
professor and head of school of drama
dr. Peter Cook
good evening it's an honor and a
privilege to be a part of Broadway's
biggest night as president of Carnegie
Mellon University home of the nation's
first degree granting drama program I
see firsthand the importance of
education and its impact on the human
condition the impact of education
especially in the Fine Arts and we are
here tonight to recognize and celebrate
that impact last year carnegie mellon
university became the first ever higher
education partner of the Tony Awards and
introduced the excellence in theatre
education award along with our partners
at the Broadway League and the American
Theatre Wing we set out to honor those
who deserve their share of the spotlight
our teachers
good evening as an educator myself and a
longtime fan of the Tony Awards I've
watched countless Tony winners take the
stage and thank a teacher who inspired
them along the way so last year we
announced an on-air challenge in which
anyone across America could nominate a
kindergarten through 12th grade theatre
teacher for this special recognition in
a nationwide campaign we promoted the
opportunity and the response was
tremendous more than 4,000 applications
were submitted in a moment we will
present the first-ever excellence in
theatre education award however first
please take a look at our finalists all
I ever wanted to be as a little girl was
to be a performer
yeah I would just like to say thank you
to the people who inspire us creatively
like teachers
each student is like a Christmas present
and when they enter the room she is so
excited to open that Christmas present
Donald Hickam believes theater can
change the world in students lives and
in this belief he has helped so many
take a moment and look around all of you
I am grateful to and I want you to be
grateful towards each other
and now to present the award please
welcome CMU alum two-time Tony winner
and my girlfriend Judith Light such a
good boyfriend as a graduate of Carnegie
Mellon University I am so proud to
support my alma mater and serve as one
of the judges for the excellence in
theatre education award as Peter shared
the quality of the entries exceeded all
expectations they came from nearly every
state in the country from cities and
towns far and wide and they had one
thing in common each teacher had changed
the lives of their students in
remarkable and momentous ways you just
saw finalists Marianne Adams from the
Grand Street Theatre School in Helena
Montana and Donald hicken from the
Baltimore School for the Arts in
Baltimore Maryland now it is my great
pleasure and honor to introduce a
history maker the first ever winner of
the excellence in theatre education
award presented by Carnegie Mellon
University and the Tony Awards from
Charlotte North Carolina's Northwest
School of the Arts teacher corey
mitchell
you
thank you thank you all I don't accept
this just for me I accept this on the
behalf of every theater teacher and
every young student out there who
aspires to this stage and to Broadway I
am overwhelmed and so appreciative thank
you to Carnegie Mellon University thank
you to the Broadway League and thank you
to the American Theatre Wing you have
been extraordinary and I appreciate it I
could not do this without thinking my
own teachers Debbie Miller Terry Rodgers
and my hero mr. Lucas Cola and finally I
have to say this thank you for
legitimizing us dear education matters
and art matters and we thank you good
night
you